[Music]
magress maggie siff stars in the hit
series billions opposite actors Paul
Giamatti and Damian Lewis SIF plays
Wendy Rhodes
the wife of US attorney Chuck Rhodes
she's the in-house performance coach for
acts Capital a hedge fund run by her
husband's nemesis billionaire Bobby
Axelrod here is a preview of the season
3 finale let's do this thing
remember they're not buying your
proprietary trading platform they're not
buying your strategies they're buying
you remind them that we have the answers
that they are safe in your loving arms
like Barry White no he'd have had the
man's in the air weeping and singing
along so yes exactly like Barry White
Gillian's hairs on Showtime a division
of CBS maggie siff good morning good
morning good morning and welcome thank
you I'm so happy to be wendy is caught
between these two men who are you know
at each other where so where is she at
the in the series right now well in the
series right now she's you know there's
there's been a slight kind of Dyneema or
like peace between the two Titans and
they're kind of each engaged in their
own major struggle with different
adversaries so in some ways it's a more
comfortable position for Wendy than
she's been and I feel like she can fully
kind of devote herself to like doing her
job at axe capital and sort of being a
partner to her husband and but they're
both gearing up for big fights so
everybody is kind of like in a
heightened you described condition
described her role at axe capital what
she does what her kind of official role
is and then wow she expands that role
so she's the in-house psychotherapist
slash performance coach for these these
traders but in particular she's sort of
axes right-hand woman so she's you know
she's sort of part constantly Airy part
you know pep-talk part like the only
person who can get through to him when
nobody else can get through to him like
in the last episode you saw her like
knock on his meditation room door and
walk in
nobody else I you know I've talked about
this before but your characters one the
most fascinating because your this
performance coach counseling people
trying to perhaps bring out the best or
the worst in them but this season I I
had the sense that she was also
manipulating people yes there's gonna
slight not over good well yes I would
say I would say where she sits morally
is a little more more ambiguous more
tangled up and
law herself she's been implicated she's
had to do things to protect her family
things that you've never seen her do
before and that's that's brought her a
little bit closer to the moral compass
of those two those two guys which has
actually been a really interesting
component for the character because you
see the the kind of depth and charged
that she can have when she chooses to
exhort exert more because the men in the
show your husband Chuck Rhodes who is
the Attorney General he skates around
like this around the law and even
personally now to see in the beginning I
thought in the first two seasons you
were sort of the straight and narrow
yeah kind of also navigate this ya know
it's funny it's like as a as a character
I think it's easy to get attached to
being kind of morally righteous and to
and to sort of enjoy playing that
position but as an actress I sort of
feel like in a way it's more interesting
you get a more 360 degree sort of
perspective on on a person who's
imperfect I mean so I've really welcomed
those changes because I think it's given
me more room to play and it's made the
character a lot weirder and kind of more
dimensional he's totally a multivalent
character I don't think people know you
worked at a Wall Street hedge fund in
the twenties which is interesting in and
of itself that is a tip that has gotten
out in just a little bit I mean the
thing about this this show is it
humanizes what's happening on Wall
Street which we know largely in terms of
like numbers and crimes and news and so
forth how did that experience shape how
you play this character so that was a
very brief job that I had I maybe did it
for three weeks okay my my friend a
friend of mine from high school was
dating a guy who was a trader or a hedge
fund who worked at a hedge fund and as a
favor he gave me a job because I was an
out-of-work actor and he was like you
seemed maybe a little bit smart I'll
share all hi come on I'll hire you and I
I just helped him do like research and
but mostly I didn't understand anything
that was going on and I was like I need
an acting job really well you sure
understand acting
figures that one out of the shell of the
show the season three finale of billions
airs this Sunday on Showtime and our
minor you can hear more of CBS this
morning on our podcast and itunes and
Apple's podcast app you are watching CBS
this morning